we are on who's here
the applicants will have up to 15
minutes to present their case
which will then be followed by various
representations including environmental
health with up to 10 minutes for the uh
for their contribution and the
suggestion has been made that the
representations from licensing are set
out in the report which has been read by
all of us and we're going to take that
as as read
so first of all we'll do presentation
from the applicants for up to 15 minutes
then environmental health for 10 minutes
and then we'll pass over to the members
of the public now I've sketched in here
five minutes I did expect more than just
two of you so if you go over
I'm being gestured outside
yes
over
one of the main points will be covered
so
I'm just trying to assist the timing
often if you want what sorry what is
your what's your name
and you've made it you've made it
if you wanted to speak Mr America
tonight
and I I promise when we've heard the
other two I'll ask you if you're
comfortable with what's been said
and whether a lot you want to add
anything else so no worries with that
thank you
the applicant please whichever order you
wish to go in
with anticipation
I'm telling you to switch your
microphone off and forgetting results
are there any questions that you would
like to ask of the applicants at this
point before you've made your case
anything you'd like to ask me
you'll have the opportunity to say that
yeah no okay
fine
right thank you for that
that's kind of ask you that you
mentioned that in your segment please
thank you
it'd be pretty chilly shall be to say no
very quick one
limited to questions
um sorry I didn't say that I was going
to make any recommendations
but just in relation to the slide that
you provide that's very important what
you haven't though
premises called Vienna which closed at
9pm and the rear doors
for the benefits of residents living
very close to the coast Drug Center we
will be delivered because it closures
and everybody is thrown out in the rear
Garden at 9pm this will be open until 12
times happening create Some Noise how
you could sleep in three of our
properties and it's extremely important
missed off that because the railways
open till 1 30.
we didn't at the beginning mention that
items in the report we were going to
take as read
environmental health do you want to add
anything or do you want to say anything
at this point
um not as part of it okay
I'm struggling to see another option
that you might have later
I just
please feel free to expand
yours
[Music]
as well as patrons entering and leaving
the premises talking shouting singing
arguing Etc there we go we're working uh
especially late at night and also you
know vehicles uh coming to pick people
up or drop people off taxis uh you've
got noise from that uh people and diesel
engines Etc car ons you know whatever
that might be
um they alt Avenue is situated one one
two two one one four Ashley Road we've
established that and the proposed
application for rail Tavern um is asking
for
um
the hours to sell alcohol Sunday to
Wednesday 10 a.m to midnight uh and from
10 a.m um to 1am on Thursday Friday and
Saturday
uh recording music is is the same as a
one I've just uh outlined and souls live
music and so it's late night refreshment
so having regard uh to the nature and
type and location of the premises and
the close proximity to nearby
residential accommodation situated on
Ashley Road and Spring Road
it is my opinion that the proposed hours
are too late operating to the operating
to the proposed times could have a
detrimental impact to nearby residents
especially during the evenings and more
specifically the weekends when the
majority of people are off work and
resting
the potential impacts of nuisance from
licensed premises are likely to be
exacerbated during the summer months
when people need to open the windows
ventilation purposes but also the noise
Ingress late at night
for the reasons outlined above I'd
recommend that the hours be brought back
the closing hours to 2300 for all
activities
um and I was just stressing before that
I don't know if people admit that
obviously you know as people consume
more alcohol and the night goals aren't
people become more boisterous and that's
generally when we get complaints which
is later at night rather than earlier on
in the evening
we'll see if this works um thanks for
that we heard earlier from the applicant
that there is a very nearby licensed
premises licensed till o130 yep so
presumably what you've just described is
a risk from that premise as well so why
would a limit be put on one operator but
not another it's question one yeah and
question two is from that parade cluster
of license premises are there is there
like a police record of complaints and
an action that requires concern
so uh to your first question
um another premises nearby premises
might have a license until 1 30.
um that's really not down to us as
environmental health uh that's that's a
historic
um you know application that's been put
in and that was decided at the time as
being you know deemed reasonable
um I can only speak to this application
because this is the application that
I've been asked to consult on So You
Know other applications all the other
premises might have different licenses
to different times
um the the thing to establish here is as
well this is a new business and a new
operator in this area I I accept that
the gentleman
um has operated in other premises for a
number of years but this is a new
business for this area I believe that
these premises haven't been occupied for
at least a couple of years
um so you know um I think that there
needs to be an history needs to be some
kind of you know um example show that
they can manage these premises properly
um going forward we have we have a
history with the other premises we can
do a search yes and we do key records
and complaints that we that we get from
those premises
so we'll keep those on a database
so the second question I'll rephrase it
is this area
known as a hot spot for
noise nuisance and complaints I would I
would say in from what I've seen no
um but that doesn't mean that we don't
get complaints and we haven't had
complaints
um that doesn't you know if I did a
search on our database I would find
complaints
boy you know the the applicant this
applicant there are no complaints the
the I think the the only complaint that
we had was something back in 2013 of
these premises the specific uh premises
are licensing is is not to duplicate any
existing Provisions containing of the
legislation so if there's publicly
already existing noise nuisance problems
then why not serve an abatement notice
and deal with it under the Environmental
Protection act as opposed to trying over
restrict and do something which is
unproportionate and
based on no evidence of this premise
we are we are aware of that
consideration but thank you for raising
yeah that we do operate in this area the
King George is that's where we're
operating in now
I think uh the question the question
should probably be have there been any
um licensing reviews in the area to
which you are aware of any premises
um on that on the licensing section
might be able to help with that
and and the second question would be
have any have any noise abatement
notices been served on any premises in
the area
not to my knowledge no thank you
thank you for that
[Music]
go ahead I'll stop you if it's not a
question
um
on Monday
so we've been a very very short space
there's three properties which you
reality careers
a terrific amount of noise it's going to
be 150 people in in London
can I interrupt you're going Way Beyond
the question at the moment between the
necessities of the three properties
creating noise towards the
presidential properties of Spring Road
and the joining
these hail talent and the other
properties
chair I'd have to I'd have to advise you
legally
that you have to look at the
applications as they are presented to
you and there is no mechanism in the
licensing Acts rightly or wrongly that
allows you to look at multiple
applications there used to be
historically what were called
sufficiency Provisions but those were
removed from the legislation of the 2003
regime was brought into Force so it is
no longer acceptable for a licensing
subcommittee to look into into a
situation and say well there's adequate
sufficiency here and if we have another
premises it'll cause more noise so so
well
yeah but sorry Mr Simpson the issue
the issue is it's not something that
could be taken into account
basically the current
levels a restaurant
these are points you can make these are
points you can make later but not now
predominantly rather than a restaurant
is it more likely not that there'll be
more noise generated for a business like
that but if it was just a restaurant
the simple answer to that is you're
asking me to put to predict the future
um and any premises it's down to how
it's managed so if it's got good
Management in it and good systems and
procedures then you know I would say you
know you wouldn't get any complaints but
if it isn't then you could get
complaints I mean we can't predict the
future we just don't know
thank you for that
that question was a little stretching it
but you can make that point in your
representation in a few minutes time
thank you
okay one of the requests that's been
made I know to you prior to this meeting
is that we should try to
reduce the level of repetition
in your presentations now because of
that I'm going to ask you now have you
agreed an order
in which you're going to presentation
do you have any preferences
okay
um we will do that in that case so if we
can start by the door
and you have five minutes
but then move on to you and then on to
the third gentleman and then we'll
finish with the representation from I
believe porcupine yeah are we all happy
with that
let's move
thank you
one minute
can I ask you to finish now please
[Music]
we've made the point at least partially
that the very very distinct difference
between where these properties are and
the rest of Hell Village is that there
is no if you go out the other side of
the of the Railway all the properties
down there do not have Residential
Properties immediately either in front
of them or behind them it's distinctly
different you are in an area which apart
from the few properties of one of which
is yours which is fully residential
and yes there have been complaints about
the
um the railway and it's it's operation
However the fact that they have a
license until 1 30 is hardly
justification for you to have anything
similar their situation is wrong from
the resident's point of view and for you
to have anything comparable would also
be wrong
we're quite lucky actually that at the
moment there is a resident who does a
rubbish pick on a Saturday morning and a
Sunday morning and I've watched them and
I've talked to him and he feels a black
bin liner in 300 yards
so yes rubbish is an issue
we've had history of what was originally
hell Wine Bar its next existence
apparently is going to be la baradino
where there were 150 people and they had
an open garden and that property is
immediately behind my house and it's
separated by a two meter alleyway
it was absolute chaos both from our
point of view and from the police's
point of view and everybody else we
don't want to go there again
I find it quite difficult to separate
what the licensing board is responsible
for and what planning is for because the
two go together so I'm making the point
firstly that in how Tavern on your
proposed plans you show the first floor
as being a licensed area
that area has already been specified by
the planning Authority from the
beginning that it was not to be it was
to only be residents
[Music]
whether you like it or not planning and
Licensing are too yes I'm saying that if
they are we cannot consider I'm not
asking you to I'm asking you to not
allow a license to be applied to an area
which is defined as residential which is
bleeding into planning no it is not
considered I'm talking about Opera
granting this is my committee I think
you're bleeding into a different area so
I understand your concerns but we cannot
discuss that in any detail at this
meeting thank you
you've got
thank you
again it's just all right because the
remaining ones that we wish to bring up
actually are covered by planning
and we what we would say is that at the
moment
it would appear that either you're not
aware of the planning constraints or
you're choosing to try and ignore them
which is not acceptable and is on my my
Reckoning that means that it also the
licensing should be considering the
constraints which are already in place
that's it
[Music]
um yeah I I just said I didn't think I'd
be speaking this evening but I've
discussed it with Paul and
you've explained that we can't make
which was one of the primary issues
but I just would like to reiterate to
you that you do you must surely take
into consideration the proximity of
three promises creating noise nuisance
there is the railway Pub which we know
is open till 1 30. yes we do the this
applicant will be open till 12 with live
music
and with the use of The Terrace at the
back which is improved your planning but
we won't go any further than that
and there is then to be La Bandera which
is a huge restaurant with 150 people
sitting and eating with live music again
and with all of this noise from three
premises coming out to the rhubarb
properties that surely must be
restriction and all I can ask and you
will know better than we no because we
don't deal with planning we are late
people in this respect we have no idea
how a premise is called the elk could
have a licensing restriction which
restricts it till 9 pm and I've been in
that Pub and at 9 00 PM everybody has to
leave the rear and the rear doors are
closed so the noise from the rear of
that property doesn't go to the houses
which are some distance away at the rear
so it's been considered in hail Village
before
the the problem with noise nuisance and
a very severe restriction has been
imposed and I don't know why
it's being recommended that it'd be 11
p.m whereas previously it's been 9pm
when clearly the same arguments have
been raised so
it seems completely contradictory
and I really do stress please take into
account we've gone through three
properties would potentially 500 people
creating movies
I couldn't possibly sleep that night all
of the physical and mental effects of
life
of our lifestyles
and so please ask you if you can
restrict it to 9pm do so restrict the
opening of the doors and strictly until
9pm and absolutely no on outside after
night here
and please you know do the best that you
can to help us as residents to enjoy a
degree of enjoyable life if you live
there at least this is a residential
family area
is on the back of the properties and
people who lived directly next door to
it
would be a terrible life to them
thank you for that I
wherever we can we will I'll undertake
that
but within the limitations play Slumbers
by our framework
which brings us to
the amazing little antique shop that I
discovered when I came to visit the
summit over the weekend oh right yes I
did not know it was there
right she's actually been there Val
Martin on whose behalf I'm speaking
she's actually
um run her business there and lived
there for the last near enough 38 years
so she's seen a lot of coming and going
over those times
was mentioned earlier on that somebody
had been in and consulted with her
um and pointed out that there was a
living area downstairs
Valerie tells me that nobody has
consulted her or to the best of her
knowledge being into the premises to
have a look uh she is unfortunately at
the moment going to be sandwiched by
these two applicants which you don't
really want me to mention but
nevertheless I think does need to be
stressed the if you like
peaceful enjoyment of her property is
going to be severely affected by what is
proposed with these late opening hours
she has a beautiful garden at the back
but if there's going to be outside
seating and people sitting there into
the late hours of the evening then
enjoying her garden particularly in the
summer is no longer going to happen I
think something else that need to be
pointed out is that these are actually
very old buildings although some of them
have new frontages and
um the uh in parts of the buildings
there's only one brick would you believe
between the two buildings
so noise transmits very easily as does
vibration and if there's going to be
live music and
um deep noises bass noises and so forth
you even get vibrations through the
other vibrations that come through are
from the
um sort of plants on the outside of the
building at the back it's batch of hands
and all the rest of it
um and as for keeping your windows open
you know in the month of June if it's
going to be repeated this very hot
weather we'll be more well it'll be
impossible you won't get a night's sleep
that's for sure
I was a bit surprised to learn also that
Val was not notified about any of this
nothing in writing she was told to go
and look at the front doors at this
closed building to find out about the
licensing application
there was mention of a noise management
plan now I don't know who's seen that
but Valerie certainly hasn't
so to be interesting to know what that
covers the other point I'm wondering
about is whether it's relevant for you
tonight is have made
greater Manchester police have any input
into these proposed opening hours
because
my personal thought is that that would
be relevant I I can help you there Miss
Lewis they are one of the statutory
consultants in Greater Manchester police
were notified of the application as they
are bound to be and they have made no
representations
in terms of the publication of the
notices
um that has followed the applicant has
followed the statutory requirements
which are the blue notice in front of
the premises an advertisement in the
press and it appears on the council's
website together with the report
right okay
sorry
and are they happy with the proposal
that you've come forward with
is it not just statutory requirement
that somebody who's so affected as
Valerie is would have cited a document
like that
and Facebook pages and also spoke to the
local councilors who said that they
would contact local residents as their
counselors and provide my direct contact
details and I offered to do a local
public event in the church hall or in
the King George with John and
unfortunately the situation you've got
well it's got lost in the process I mean
as a matter of fact Valerie doesn't use
a computer she's one of those rare
people if you like these days who
doesn't but that's no excuse for her
being sidetracked quite frankly I think
we're drifting slightly away from the
structure of this world could I ask you
just what what now you've had your five
notes just wind up what you want to say
to us in terms of a representation and
then we'll move on to questions thank
you
I think the main point is
that I'm struggling to make is that the
licensing I should be severely
restricted for all the reasons that
you've heard over the last few minutes
it's supposed to be
sorry to be technical about it the word
the Savior questions
rubbish
you don't sell anything to take away
there's no rubbish coming from the
premises it is literally about all
certainly inside there is no taking
whatever it is
available no no
it's connected to the uh consumption of
alcohol can I be rude and interrupt
again
I'm not hearing question marks on these
sentences
thank you
[Music]
um
no more questions on that
so
we've heard representations
[Music]
it's fairly obvious they're not in your
application
completely
[Music]
and insulated on the inside I've also
put in the conditions
all windows will be known for any
um I think we're we're straying into
we're ensuring into matters that are
within your noise management plan
thank you
thank you for your contribution
[Music]